Sal: Here are some questions that I got
from Malibu Magazine, so I
thought I would answer them.
Question number 1: Your
videos began as a means
of tutoring your cousins
and now exist as a resource
to educate the world, which
must be hugely inspiring.
Yes, it is, and a bit surreal.
Your model is hyper-scalable
because any one lecture
can be viewed an infinite
number of times anywhere,
but it's also very dependent
on your personal input.
Do you ever feel overwhelmed by the idea
of having to record one more,
or based on expectations
hundreds of more videos, or
ever questioned the notion
you should be the Khan
Academy's only lecturer?
On the first part, do I
ever feel overwhelmed?
Not in the way that I guess it
sounds like this is phrasing.
Actually this is what is
really exciting about me
and almost from my own
selfish point of view,
this is one of the reasons
why I love doing this
is that I get to spend the rest of my life
doing what I really
enjoy, which is teaching,
and many times learning and teaching,
or teaching myself a new
way of looking at something
or getting to make
connections between things
that I've never been
able to have the luxury
to explore before, so
I view it as a luxury
more than something
that would overwhelm me.
I really love this aspect of getting
to do more and more videos,
and I hope that as long as I live I'm able
to continue making videos,
and at least hundreds more per year.
Even though there is a
lot of responsibility
of the organization and
being one of the people
who help manage what is
now this organization
that's beyond me, the
Khan Academy, I always
want to be spending a
significant amount of my time
making videos because
that's really what I love.
The second part of it,
do you ever question
the notion that you should be
the Academy's only lecturer?
That's a big yes.
But the answer to that has
never been completely obvious.
I think one of the
reasons why we've gotten
a lot of traction is the
consistency and the trust.
When you learn from
someone, it actually takes
a lot of trust to invest your
own mental cycles in them.
I think people have learned
to trust the Khan Academy.
We never thought that it
should be this kind of thing
that everyone can throw videos on.
In fact, there are already
things and its called YouTube
or other things like it.
It's jarring when you
have different quality
and you have different
teachers, even if they are good.
That's what we struggled with.
We also think that there's
kind of an understanding,
an agreement with the student that content
on the Khan Academy will focus on
conceptual development over
mechanical understanding,
it will be conversational, it
won't talk down to the student,
it will talk to everyone
as if they are smart,
but not talk in a way
that assumes that someone
knows all of the terminology
or not talk past people.
It's been very important that we bring ...
Nothing sounds scripted.
Everything sounds authentic.
Everything is directly
coming from a person;
that it's a person-to-person
communication,
not a corporation-to-person communication.
These are surprisingly
hard things to find.
We've been searching.
What you'll see in the next few months
is we actually are bringing
on some other lecturers,
in particular the humanities,
who will be lecturers in the humanities.
I love them.
The videos that I've watched
of theirs made me wish
that I had them as teachers
when I was growing up.
I hope other people
have that same reaction.
The other thing that
people have begun to notice
is the last few weeks
we've been experimenting
with bringing contributors
in who I kind of interview.
We're experimenting with that forum factor
to see if it's something that makes sense
or maybe something that just compliments
the broader library.
I'll always be doing the
independent, traditional,
Sal teaching type of thing.
I've really been enjoying
getting these experts in
and being able to kind
of play the student role.
So the simple answer is,
yes, we have questioned it
and over the next few
months you're going to see,
actually, the faculty of the Khan Academy
expand in a pretty substantial way.
Question number 2: One of
the most difficult things
for people to wrap their
heads around is the idea
that you're not interested
in monetizing the Academy.
Cold hard cash pales next
to the intrinsic value
of the tools you've create
and their attendant legacy,
but if the Academy will
never be a source of wealth,
do you think you'll
eventually turn your attention
to another, for-profit driven venture?
The simple answer is no, no.
I've gone through the mental
simulation multiple times.
If someone were to give
me a billion dollars,
this is exactly what I would want to do.
So I get a chance to do it now.
Regardless of whatever happens,
if for whatever reason you see Sal saying,
"Hey, I'm done with the Khan Academy,
"I now want to go start
managing money again,"
or if I want to go start doing X or Y,
people should wonder
whether I've been abducted
and replaced by someone else.
I consider myself the
luckiest person on the planet
that I get to do what I'm doing now,
and hopefully for the rest of my life,
and hopefully it's a decent,
respectably long life,
but you never know.
Yes, and you've articulated
in the question exactly.
I'm not someone who doesn't mind
a little bit of cold, hard cash,
but at the same time the
satisfaction of people
really enjoying the stuff,
we're genuine about it.
We really love it.
I think it's not just me,
it's most of our team.
If you look at the people
on the Khan Academy team,
some of them are actually very well known
in their respective domains.
Even the ones that aren't well known,
they really are all rock stars.
We are really bringing on ...
This is really the most amazing team
that I've ever worked with
and I've worked with a lot
of very, very smart people in the past.
They've all turned away
higher paying jobs,
jobs at pre-IPO companies where they could
make millions of dollars,
to work on this project.
It's not just me, I am
actually surrounded by people
who are similarly
inspired by this mission.
I hope that they continue
to want to do this
for a long time.
Question number 3: When you
say that you'd like to make
the Academy self-sustaining
in 5 years, what do you mean?
If you don't charge for the videos,
what will be the source of funding?
This not charging for the videos,
this is kind of core to our religion
of the Khan Academy,
not that Khan Academy's a religion,
but core of what we hold dear.
That's true also for our software.
As far as what the source
of funding will be,
it's an open question.
There's ideas on the table.
I don't know what all of the ideas are.
We are building, hopefully,
a trusted brand here.
Maybe the way Sesame does
it, they license Elmo out!
(laughs) I say that half jokingly,
but that's one way that Sesame Street
has supported themselves.
We think we're kind of like Sesame Street
but for older kids and adults
in terms that we're making
learning approachable for them.
Maybe that type of model might work.
We do hope that foundations continue
to support us forever, to some degree.
We don't want to be 100% reliant on that,
but we do think relative
to the impact it's having,
our budget is still smaller
than most individual schools,
even elementary schools.
We're able to reach
millions of students now,
and that same content
that's already produced
can reach tens of millions
for a long, long time.
We also hope that our
user base supports us.
We definitely don't mind if people say,
"Wow, that really helped me.
"Let me go to PayPal"
or "Let's send Khan Academy $20"
or "Let me give them $5 from
my paycheck every month,"
if they can afford it.
We hope that people
are already doing that,
and as our user base grows,
we think that could also help us.
So, the simple answer is
we always want to have
no barrier to accessing the knowledge,
but we do think that there will be ways
over the next 5-10 years
so that we can at least
support our base salaries
and our operating expenses
so that this resource never goes away.
We don't want to be complacent about that,
so I do encourage people to donate.
Question number 4: What influence have
the Gates Foundation
and other donors had on
the scope or evolution of the Academy?
Example: Is it now a
collaborative effort, and if so,
what are their objectives
and how might they differ from yours?
At a first level, our supporters,
Gates Foundation is a large supporter,
Google is another major supporter,
we've had several major
individual supporters.
They've treated us in a great way.
They're obviously people
whose opinion we really want
and want to take into
account, but they have said,
"Look, what's made Khan Academy work
"is it's kind of grassroots.
"You all have tried stuff
and you all saw what works,
"and based on what works
you keep doing more of it,
"and you keep iterating on the process."
So they've given us a lot of freedom
to explore the space
and make decisions on our own
and pursue the things that we found
or are compelling for our students.
With that said, they have
a bunch of good ideas,
so we are taking those great
ideas into consideration.
I think the one thing that especially
the Gates Foundation
has brought to the table
is that they've really
plugged us in to a lot
of the other stuff that's
going on in education
and education research and
helping to make those connections.
It's helping us, from
Khan Academy from being
this kind of quirky
thing that one guy did,
and we want to keep it a quirky thing,
but it also helps us
interface with the more
authoritative side of the education world.
Question number 5: Your
videos are now being
leveraged to drive more
intense classroom learning
by flipping the classroom, as I've said,
and as I've said in many videos,
we view the flip as halfway.
The ideal is kids using
the software and the videos
to work at their own pace anytime,
and then that they use
class time for the real
interventions and
interactions with their peers.
And you have had some very clear opinions
about how to improve the
educational experience.
I just gave one of them.
Do you have any aspirations
around a larger role
in educational reform?
I've learned, "reform"
seems like a good word,
but I've learned that
it can be a loaded word.
If this question is do
I want a role as like
a State Superintendent of Education, NO!
The answer is a very clear no.
I don't want to get involved at all
in the political debate.
I think we are valuable,
or we can be valuable,
or let me put it this way,
we strive to be valuable to everyone.
So we don't want anyone
to have a predisposition
against us just because Sal
says he feels X, Y and Z
about some hot button issue there.
If that's the question, we say no.
If it's do we want to be a catalyst
in maybe the reform conversation
being a clear-thinking
conversation, maybe.
Maybe we can provide common ground.
Maybe everyone in the debate agrees
that class time is better
spent when it's interactive;
everyone agrees that
ideally students should
be allowed to work at their own pace;
everyone agrees that teachers
are adding more value,
are going up the value chain,
when they are mentors,
when they are diagnosing students,
when they are providing things that videos
and on-demand exercises can't;
when everyone agrees
that it's really valuable
for teachers to get real time data
so that they can make those interventions
in a valuable way.
We hope that we're a catalyst
or that we have aspirations
about serving those functions
about maybe clarifying or
finding a common ground,
but I have no aspirations at
all about becoming some type
of a pundit on the political
debates around this.
Question number 6: What's
the most important thing
you've learned through the
process of establishing
and growing the Academy,
and have there been
any unintended consequences?
I think the most important
thing is I've learned
the power, and it's
something that I always
suspected, kind of, with
an engineering background,
but you need to be close to the consumer
or the end user to really
understand the problems,
and then you should try
to put something out
that's even very simple and
basic, and see if it works,
and not make any assumptions
that more technology's good
or fancier is better,
but just try to solve the need at hand,
but try to solve it quickly.
Don't try to plan and
talk about it for years
and get funding and do
all this stuff before
you've tried stuff out.
The big takeaway I've
had, it's kind of my way
I would have operated
beforehand but it's really
made me feel even strongly about this,
is build, test and iterate things,
and don't get into weeks-long debates
that focus on meanings of words
and whether one research
study is saying one thing
or the other research
study is saying the other.
Just build stuff, put it out
there, and see if it works.
The unintended consequences
is that this idea
of a lot of what Khan Academy is doing is,
I think, obvious and
people have been talking
about this for a long, long time,
but I think that attitude of just, look,
let's not talk about it,
let's do something about it
has allowed us to get traction
in a space where there really
hasn't been a lot of traction
from things like what we're doing.
Question number 7: You are super-numerate
and offer lots of performance data
to leverage teachers' efforts.
Are teachers, many of whom may not be as
naturally data-centric,
embracing these tools,
or are you finding resistance?
What other criticisms are you hearing
from professional educators
or administrators?
The first part of it, are
we finding resistance?
No, not at all.
The teachers who we've
been working closely with
who've actually been helping
to define some of these tools,
they love it.
If anything, their main feedback is,
some of the 5th grade teachers,
they teach all the subjects,
so now they feel unarmed with data
when they're teaching other subjects,
so they want us to go
into those other subjects
as quickly as possible so they
can start to have that data.
The teachers, we found,
really do love the data.
In terms of what other criticisms
are you hearing from
professional educators,
I think some criticism
is, what is new here?
Hey, isn't this just lecture?
Look, even those lectures
aren't using anything fancy.
They're just literally a
guy chatting about something
and kind of writing on a board.
They're right!
There isn't anything new here.
I think what they're missing, the point is
it's not always about the idea.
A lot is about the craftsmanship
or what happens on the ground.
I think a lot, especially
the publishing companies,
I think they miss the
point that human-to-human
interaction, it's
important with real humans,
but it's also important when it's human
interacting with a product.
They don't want to feel like
something is overproduced.
They want to feel like they're
talking to someone who cares.
It's also more important to
focus on deep understanding
and conceptual understanding
and why a subject is beautiful.
It's more important to focus on that
than on fancy graphics
and on fancy whatever.
I try to improve my penmanship
and I try to draw nice diagrams
so people understand things,
but we never are going to be that place
that says we have the fanciest graphic.
Maybe if a really fancy
graphic is compelling
we'd want to integrate it,
but we don't want to do it
just for the sake of it,
just to impress other people
in the computer graphics space
that we have the best one.
That's one kind of knee-jerk reaction
of like wait, this is pretty basic.
Why is this interesting?
The answer is it is pretty basic,
but maybe to some degree
that is why it's interesting,
that is why it's why people
are finding it compelling.
The other reaction we get
is when some people learn
about look, kids learning
at their own pace,
using software, people
using videos to learn,
they believe that this is somehow trying
to replace the classroom,
or trying to replace the
interaction with the teacher.
For us, we just think
that's a misconception.
We think we're the exact
180 degrees opposite.
We are a catalyst for enhancing
the interaction with the teacher.
The teacher will no longer
be lecturing at the students,
they will now be discussing with students.
They will now be having those small group
discussions that everyone,
I think, recognizes
is the best way to learn.
They'll now be leading projects,
that I think everyone agrees
is a really great way to learn,
especially if it's augmented with kids
getting a lot of practice
and being able to get a
lot of their core skills,
to some degree, at their own pace.
I think those are the two areas.
There's some resistance about the idea
of more voices on the Khan Academy,
and I already talked about it earlier.
We are bringing more voices to the table
and we do want to make
tools so that teachers
themselves can also
contribute to the platform.
All of that's coming and
we're going to have the crowd,
hopefully, if we can think of a good way,
curate what makes sense to add in.
But we want to do all that without losing
a lot of the consistency
and even the quirkiness
that we think makes Khan
Adademy work right now.
Number 8: The content is heavily weighted
towards math and science.
What's your plan for
building more humanities
content, and how do you choose what to add
to the site and when?
For example, what drove
the decision to add
a playlist about he
Paulson financial bailout
versus another series of history lessons?
Our plan on the humanities,
the answer is yes,
we actually are, actually
I think they accepted today
and we're going to make the announcement
once we integrate some of their work
more deeply with the
site, but we've brought on
two professors in the humanities
and I love what they've already done.
I hope everyone can start
getting excited about it
because I think they'll be pretty happy
with what they've done.
I think they've tackled the humanities
in a very interesting way.
In fact, this new technique of me doing
conversations with people,
this was inspired by them
because many of the humanities
are very subjective.
They've kind of got this really neat way
of having a conversation
about subjective things
that bring more than one way to think
about something to light,
and I think it also encourages students
to think of what their own opinions
about something are, not just to take
the professor's opinion as gospel.
Then, for example, what drove the decision
to add a playlist about the
Paulson financial bailout
versus another series of history lessons?
That one in particular was the midst
of the financial crisis
and I just saw stuff on TV
that I thought was wrong.
I was still working at a hedge fund then
and I was spending most of my time reading
the Federal Reserve Act
and I was reading all
of the details of a lot of these bailouts.
It just felt like there was huge gap
between what the public understanding was
and what the real reality was.
I also thought that it was a very
unbalanced conversation in the public,
that essentially this thing was being
steamrolled forward, the
take from the interested
parties was, "Trust us
on this; bail us out.
"If you even think about
it for another day,
"we have a gun to the economy,
"or a bomb is about to
blow up in the economy
"and we're all going to," you know,
everything's going to go
to hell in a hand basket
if we don't address those issues.
I though another more,
hopefully, rational voice
was needed because there were some very
irrational things happening.
People were asking me a lot of questions
at parties and things, so I was like, hey,
let me scale up my answer.
The general idea is
there's a constant tension
between what is a useful,
hey, look, we still
haven't done those type of algebra videos,
let's do those, and
there's just this stuff
that's current events that need answering,
and then there's just some quirky things
that I just happen to run
into that I find interesting
and I'm just dying to make
a video and I'll do those.
It's a constant balance
between all of those things.
Question number 9: Your
FAQ answer on your website
about your religion is very eloquent,
but why did you feel compelled
to put it on the site at all?
Did people, in fact, frequently ask
about your religious beliefs?
Yes.
Many people did ask about
my religious beliefs.
They wanted confirmation
one way or the other
about my religion.
I thought that that FAQ answer
was actually the best way
to address that question
because that is actually
how I feel about my religion.
Question number 10: The
American educational system
is broken in many ways,
but we also have a problem
of misallocation of
resources in that highly
educated minds gravitate
towards hedge funds,
investment banks and other
lucrative professions
and away from teaching
and other professions
that are more productive
for society as a whole.
Given your highly relevant
personal career shift,
do you have any ideas
about how to change that misallocation?
I think people go into a
career for multiple reasons.
I think one is intellectual stimulation.
Teaching is as, or more,
intellectually stimulating
than many of those other
higher paid careers.
They go into something for compensation,
and that's something where,
at least definitely at
the K through 12 level,
there isn't that compensation.
They also go into it for respect.
The one example I give here is professors.
There isn't any crisis about great minds
going into academia, even though academia
really has, the compensation academia
even though it's just
as competitive to become
a tenured professor at a great university,
or actually more competitive to become
a tenured professor at a university
than make partner at a prestigious bank
or hedge fund or private equity firm,
you still have a lot of
people going into academia
despite the lack of compensation.
They make more than K through 12 teachers,
but nowhere near what those
same people would make
if they went into industry.
I think the reason why
really, really, really
smart people, and not
say that really, really
smart people aren't going to K through 12,
but it's just their threshold of passion
has to be so high that it
overcomes these other things;
but the reason why you
have less of a problem
in the higher education
is I think you have
a high degree of respect,
and actually I'll add
independence at the
higher education level;
that to some degree the reason why you
become a professor at
university is that obviously
you get a lot of intellectual stimulation,
but you get a ton of respect,
and you get a lot of independence,
especially once you get tenure.
I think the solution
here is get compensation,
compensation is important.
Compensation has to go up.
I think it has to at least get comparable
to university professors.
This day and age, that's
definitely a lot higher
than where teachers are paid right now,
but they don't have to get to
investment banking salaries.
I think even more importantly,
they have to be fields
where teachers can
express their creativity
and they're given much
more power and respect
than, in a lot of cases,
they're given right now.
Definitely even independence.
I think this is a role that we have.
Every iteration, every
time government officials
panic about the education system,
they just micromanage it more.
That might, in their minds,
de-risk the worst that's going on,
but it also handicaps
the best that's going on.
It forces teachers to
lose their independence.
We hope what we're advocating
is that it makes the teachers,
it gives them more independence to do
what they want with class time
because so much of the core stuff
students can do through the Khan Academy.
Then the last question, extra credit:
What is the next big step for the Academy?
I hinted at this several times.
We are expanding the faculty,
so that is a really big thing.
Outside of that, we are just continuing
to layer on more features.
We're adding a lot more
content on the exercise side.
I think you'll start to see,
in the next 6 months to a year,
exercises that go beyond
our core math core.
Our videos, obviously,
already go well beyond math,
but you'll start seeing
exercises that go beyond that.
I think the next really big
one that's going to make waves
is the faculty members that are not me.